you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
climate villains the charge leveled
against the uk by greta thundberg and
vanessa nakate the two keynote speakers
at the pre-cop 26 youth event warnings
of illegal deforestation in protected
areas of the amazon reach record levels
we investigate who's behind it
and how illicit drugs taken at
glastonbury have worked their way into a
river and threatened already endangered
eels
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
there's now just over a month to go
until the cop 26 climate summit begins
in glasgow but today a three-day pre-cop
youth event got underway in milan with a
scathing message for the summit's hosts
from the keynote speakers greta
thundberg and the ugandan climate
activist vanessa nacate
they accused the uk of being climate
villains and of textbook hypocrisy over
the granting of new licenses to extract
north sea oil and gas
well the pair were speaking to our
climate change correspondent hannah
thomas peter who joins us now live from
milan hannah
and the youth movement to tackle the
climate crisis is ambitious it has high
ideals and it is judgmental and so
dozens hundreds of activists have
gathered here in milan at this youth cop
event to deliver the message to world
leaders that their best just simply
isn't good enough
climate change activist greta tunberg
arriving at youth cop a u.n climate
change meeting in milan
a slightly reluctant celebrity although
comfortable enough to give a defiant and
dismissive speech about the failure of
politicians to tackle global warming
this is not about some expensive
politically correct green act of bunny
hugging or blah blah blah
build back better blah blah blah green
economy blah blah blah
net zero by 25 our hopes and dreams
drown in their empty words and promises
these words will ring in the ears of
world leaders as they gather for the
next major climate summit being held in
glasgow later this year known as cop26
and tunburg along with ugandan activist
vanessa nocate had some harsh criticism
for the country in charge
the uk is very good at creative carbon
accounting
um
excluding emissions and etc etc
which
in some senses make them look like
climate leaders so it's very easy then
to to make it seem like they are taking
leadership and it's i find it very
strange that
they're like they are the ones who we
are supposed to look up to now
but they are
objectively one of the biggest climate
villains
um which i found very strange do you
think the united kingdom is a climate
villain
i think they are because true climate
leadership doesn't mean opening new
co-power plants or funding new oil
fields
i think that is not true climate
leadership i think true climate
leadership is
prioritizing the people and the planet
over profits
have you given up on them
well i haven't given up on them because
if i give up it means communities like
mine will continue to face the worst of
the climate crisis i agree with vanessa
and this is not the time to give up of
course
we are speeding in the very wrong
direction
but there are still of course many many
people who are trying and who want to do
good
bound up as it is in politics and
realism cop 26 in glasgow is unlikely to
meet the high ideals of the youth
climate movement they may not have given
up but they probably will be
disappointed
so hannah some strong criticism there of
world leaders but will those people
attending the cop 26 summit in november
take notice of what's being said in
milan
[Music]
well it's hard to ignore things that
greta tunberg says she is a global
celebrity when it comes to climate
change movement just apologize for the
drumming in the background at the end of
the day here in milan and people are
deading off some steven listening to
some live music
but alok sharma the uk's president of
26 has has just said in a speech to
these youth activists that the rising
tide of anxiety about
a lack of action on climate change is
the shame of his generation and he knows
he's still got some huge problems to
solve before everyone gathers in glasgow
there is no agreement for example on how
to phase out coal there still isn't
enough funding for developing nations to
tackle the climate crisis
and dozens and dozens of countries still
have not submitted more ambitious plans
to reduce carbon emissions all of those
things need to get sorted it doesn't
look like there's a clear path to a
solution for any of them
and so boris johnson and alok sharma and
all of the other world leaders gathering
in glasgow are going to have a real task
on their hands
hannah thanks very much indeed
let's take a look at some of those other
climate news now and levels of cocaine
and mdma high enough to harm wildlife
have been detected in the river running
through the site of glastonbury festival
researchers from the center for
environmental biotechnology have
discovered the populations of the
european eel a critically endangered
species are being affected
revelers have been asked to use toilets
provided by organizers in future as the
drugs may have entered the river as a
result of public urination
an installation of a lifelike face of a
young girl drowning in the tide has
appeared in spain as the tides rise and
fall the fiberglass figure is submerged
and uncovered each day and according to
the artist reuben orosco is a warning of
the consequences of climate change
and scientists are spraying droplets of
ocean water into the sky to form clouds
in an effort to save australia's great
barrier reef researchers working on the
cloud brightening project are using
microscopic sea particles to thicken
existing clouds and reduce sunlight
this in turn lowers the ocean's
temperature which prevents coral from
becoming bleached
now deforestation in the most protected
parts of the amazon could reach record
levels this year analysis by sky's data
and forensics unit of brazil's
deforestation
system shows a record area of forest
covered by warnings that illegal
clearing may be taking place
so let's take a look then at the map and
you can see the dark dots that you can
see here are deforestation alerts
recorded between january and august of
this year and they cover more than 2
300 square miles of forest
now over 9 000 square miles have been
affected since jaya bolsonaro became
president in 2019. and this increase is
affecting designated conservation areas
protected by law and that's the green
areas that you can see here
now jamaican is a protected national
park which borders the remote town of
novo progresso now deforestation alerts
here are five times higher under
president bolsonaro than they were in
the two years before he took office
well sky news's data and forensics unit
has discovered who's behind some of this
illegal deforestation in this area
victoria elms reports
illegal deforestation by cattle ranchers
gold miners and loggers is happening
right across the brazilian amazon
and in protected areas like the jamaican
national forest in the state of para the
issue is getting worse
satellite images like these show us that
deforestation is happening in remote
parts of the forest that are difficult
for authorities on the ground to detect
in june 2020 this area appears untouched
but by july 2021 the area is patchy and
brown
the area is being deforested and we
found out who's behind it the
neighbouring plot of land gave us a clue
it's an area registered to a key
political figure in novo progresso
he's one of four consecutive former
mayors of the town to have been fined
for damaging protected parts of the
forest his one-time deputy who's now the
mayor of novo progresso was fined as
recently as august 2020
but how does that relate to our other
plot
well
using information given to us by
brazil's environmental protection agency
and public databases we found that this
fine was handed to the current mayor's
mother martus mulsky dill
she's twice run for novo progresso
council and runs a hotel in the town
we wrote to ms dill about this but
received no response but it's not just
local political leaders there's a whole
web of individuals deforesting the area
for profit
businessman ezekiel castaneda was one of
24 local people arrested in 2014 and
2015 in a major criminal investigation
authorities called him the biggest
deforester in the amazon at the time
industry leaders and politicians in novo
progresso have campaigned for years to
reduce the size of the jamaican national
forest
they feel the status of the park is an
unfair restriction for those who moved
to the area decades ago on the promise
of economic prosperity
the current mayor met with brazil's vice
president to discuss the cause last
month it's a view that president xi
bolsonaro's government is sympathetic to
what is new is that you have a federal
government where the president is saying
that he doesn't like environmental ngos
they're they're echo terrorists he's
signaling to local politicians that the
federal government is no longer
necessarily
a guardian of the forest and under his
environment ministers
the the whole infrastructure is becoming
immobilized
president bolsonaro said last week that
increased efforts to tackle illegal
activity have meant that deforestation
rates fell over 30 in august compared to
the same month last year
but as our investigation shows
deforestation levels have remained
consistently high since he came into
office and its politicians and leaders
at all levels who are allowing it
victoria elms sky news
and you can hear from one of our data
and forensics journalists about how this
exclusive report came together in this
week's episode of sky news climate cast
and we also discussed why the amazon is
so precious and a vital tool in the
fight against climate change and that's
available now wherever you normally get
your podcast from
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'm going to be joined by dr shihu
from the university of oxford's
environmental change institute and a
senior associate at the energy and
climate intelligence unit and
environmental consultant richard black
they're standing ready and waiting right
now we're going to be discussing the
impact brett of thundberg has had on the
world and if we're too reliant on the
amazon rainforest
[Music]
[Music]
everyone will be taking a lateral flow
test and we will be checking that at
registration when they pick their
running number um and in picking up
their running number they're going to
hand over their the bag of the kits that
they want to wear once they've finished
this means that we have more space at
the finish area on the mouth and at the
start what we've done is put everyone
into
40 over 40 different waves of runners um
so that we've spread the start over an
hour and a half so the course will be
less crowded um and uh
this is outdoors everyone will have had
this lateral flow test huge amount of
money being raised for charity and
outdoors is the best place you could
possibly be we've had an incredibly
difficult last 20 months
we've been in our homes we've been
missing being with people we've been a
part that sense of community has been
lost and i think that uh
with all the procedures that we've put
in place and we work with the government
the events research program that we put
in place um for an event that took place
at kempton park back in may then we did
one in in july the first closed road
event in london later on in july and
then the vitality big half in august
we've been gradually testing various
procedures getting these events bigger
and we are very confident with what
we're doing and uh people doing these
events have been so happy to be able to
be together to feel safe and to get that
incredible sense of community
it is truly an amazing place to to come
to to visit um i'm near canada gate you
might be able to hear the canada geese
behind me um yeah and we've got elite
athletes uh we charted a plane from
kenya in ethiopia that arrived at
heathrow this morning so the late
athletes have started to come in and and
again it is uh you know we've got david
weir uh the greatest uh athlete in the
world in terms of uh the london marathon
he won the mini marathon six times he's
won the marathon eight times he'll be
back and uh yeah we're just so delighted
to be um to be part of this uh this
event is back after 889 days
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms
human beings directly depend on
underground water source so a lake or a
pond
to replenish these groundwater resources
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you know if more of us walked rolled
bikes and scoots to school we would make
a big difference to the air pollution
around our school yeah like us
it will be a chilly start to wednesday
with some scattered showers there will
be plenty of sunny spells through the
day but it will feel rather cool in the
breeze the showers will mainly be
focused in the west
cloud will thicken across ireland and
northern ireland later as the next
weather system approaches
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high the windy conditions will tend
to keep air pollution levels low on
wednesday
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're going
to get straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with dr
cece who from the university of oxford's
environmental change institute and
senior associate at the energy and
climate intelligence unit and
environmental consultant richard black
so good evening to both of you really
good to see you though thanks for coming
now why has greta thunderberg had such
an impact on the world how did a swedish
school girl skipping a day of school to
sit outside our country's parliament go
on to address the un and be nominated
for the nobel peace prize was it simply
the right time or are young women simply
more appealing world leaders in a world
unenthusiastic about its political
leaders so let's discuss this now and
cece to you first of all there are a lot
of eco activists out there so why do you
think greta thundberg has managed to end
up with such a large profile what's the
secret of her success do you think
yes thank you so much for having me um i
think what is so special about greta is
that she has two very unique qualities
the first one is that she has this thing
about not being afraid of being alone
and if you look at how um in the past
you know her journey she was advocating
for climate change alone for a long time
before she was noticed and she couples
this with really uh this kind of second
quality which is um this strong sense of
purpose and this you know this scent
this pup of this purpose is so
passionate that she feels really so
strongly about that her you know school
uh strike for the climate has really now
grown into a global movement she hasn't
you know inspired millions to take
action and demand action for climate
change
and clearly a huge number of people
follow her and support her but also
richie she gets a lot of criticism as
well doesn't she let's just take a look
at what
donald trump said about her he said
greta must work on her anger management
problem then go to a good old-fashioned
movie with a friend and he's not alone
she's sparked a bit of a backlash from a
number of people hasn't she so she's not
altogether popular why do you think she
attracts the criticism
i think anyone who is a successful
environmental campaigner attracts
criticism from people who do not like
environmental campaigning and she's been
spectacularly successful the biggest
kind of meteor that streaked across our
heavens uh probably the last decade or
so um it's kind of ironic really uh some
of the most vocal critics have been
newspaper columnists in in in the uk who
tend to be you know middle-aged men and
uh of course it shouldn't be an 18 year
old swedish school girl who's telling
people what to think it should be
middle-aged men writing for british
newspapers that's their job shortly
that's interesting but also cece what
about the question of whether or not
she's being listened to i mean she
obviously makes headlines but is she
having an impact i think she herself has
talked about the youth summit that's
going on in milan now saying they don't
listen to us emissions are still rising
the science doesn't lie is she cutting
through at all
i think she really is you know i think
the fact that she has managed to inspire
so many people to take action is the
fact that she is being listened to
um and the uh the government officials
there also have um
you know like opened up these
discussions for young people to to to
bring in their voice there is progress
but um you know i think there is more to
be done
in order to bring young people more
young people
onto the table and have these
discussions
what do you think richard do you think
that these young climate activists are
being heard i mean there are concerns
amongst them that they're not being they
feel
they haven't got the agency a lot of
them are too young to even vote but but
do you think that they are having an
impact
yes i think they're absolutely having an
impact um they are being heard just
coming back to one of these the the
question that you asked initially anna
what makes greta thundberg so successful
one of the key things about her and a
lot of the other young women around her
is that they are utterly authentic they
don't pretend to be scientists they
don't pretend to be you know interested
in going into government they are just
telling it as they see it and that's
massively appealing um of course with
every government there's a difference
there's a stage between accepting what
the science is and accepting what public
opinion is and then actually enacting
policy and that's the difficult bridge
and that's perhaps where they're not
quite having the impact that they would
want to have
so richard briefly do you think that cop
26
will take notice of what's been said at
the youth cop
yes i think it will take note of it
whether actually any of the because in
the end the decisions are made by
individual governments the decisions not
made by the by the un or some sort of
amorphous body like that so whether
enough individual governments uh take
note of this and of course all the other
warnings that are coming from science
and and change what they're doing that
is really the big question
cece very briefly do you agree with that
yes i i do
well that was very brief but we may as
well leave that there and move on to the
next subject seeing as you're in
agreement and the amazon rainforest is
often referred to as the lungs of the
planet it's a huge carbon sink of course
which means that it absorbs more carbon
dioxide than it emits so helping keep
the global temperature rise down
but as we've heard the amazon is being
destroyed at ever increasing rates
leading to reports that it's close to a
tipping point i.e emitting more carbon
than it absorbs so are we too reliant on
the amazon so let's uh put this question
to you richard and we're used to hearing
of the amazon rainforest as the world's
most important carbon sink so how
worrying do you find these reports of
record illegal deforestation
what will happen to climate change if we
do see the amazon starting to emit more
carbon dioxide than it absorbs
i think it is very worrying i mean the
great the three great rainforests of the
world the amazon the congo and uh in
indonesia borneo and so on um you know
have absorbed about you know a quarter
of the carbon that we've put into the
atmosphere but we know that that is
weakening it declined by something like
a third over the 30 years from from 1990
um there was a report out earlier this
year showing that in a part of the
amazon has changed from being a net
carbon absorber to a net carbon emitter
and there is a lot of science around
over the last 10 years showing that you
could get to a state where the amazon
basically goes from being a forest to
being a savannah so anything that
increases the risks of that happening i
think it'll be taken very seriously and
one thing that i picked up from your
report that is absolutely true is that
this is not an accident that this is
happening under jaya bolsonaro his
philosophy is that
uh that environmentalists and indigenous
people who oppose this kind of
development are somehow anti-brazil it's
anti-brazil's economic development and
um it's no surprise i i did a little
piece of analysis a couple of years ago
and we saw lots of forest fires breaking
out in the summer and you were seeing a
much bigger increase in forest fires in
provinces that were governed by
bolsonaro allies than in other provinces
and cece do we rely too much on the
amazon as a carbon sink are there
alternatives out there are there other
parts of the world where trees can be
planted and we can stop worrying so much
about the amazon
yeah um the amazon is really really
important so you know we must do
everything possible to protect it but
you are right i think um you know we
there are things that we can actually do
and one thing is by planting tree and a
study has actually shown that if we grow
uh one million trees and we have the
potential to keep global temperature
rises to be below uh 1.5 degrees and so
this really um
you know is a very uh hopeful in a way
so i have right good news actually so
the earth is now actually greener than
20 years ago and that's largely because
we have uh grown a lot more trees and
india and china have actually grown
enough trees to an area which is the
equivalent of the amazon forest so i
think this is really strong evidence to
show that we as human beings we are
capable of change we can change we can
do stuff together if we want to and um
i'm i'm yeah
i'm i'm just hopeful that we'll do stuff
together to solve the climate prices
it's always good to end on the word
hopeful we will leave it there dr cece
who richard black always good to see you
both thanks very much indeed
do stay with us coming up next we've got
the great debate stay tuned
[Music]
you